oh my god get over here right now the
Queen I love you so much I never cry I
never come and you are on tour with
Harry Styles who also calls man
Instagram you are just everything in the
entire world we have a little edgier
music trailer different Park doesn't
matter like you are everything Golden
Hour is the greatest album of our
generation I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
you said it it really is but but we have
to talk about the kendall Jenner of it
all because homegirl blurs you out of
her Instagram patented do you follow her
on Instagram did you see her you found
out yeah I know I know I saw it I saw
myself like I thought I was like oh but
honestly no shade you know you never
know how those things like she's right
and then she tweeted she's a big fan no
she loves and ran into her like one of
the Harry shows and whatever but did you
speak oh wait you ready - Harry show
were they together
gossiped I'm not sure inspiration what
was that like like where the girls so
loud I've been to a Harry Styles concert
and like I was deaf I've been out you're
on your own time we got to get to New
York second show at Beacon Theatre cause
the first one sold out yes I'm very
excited be excited because I haven't
been there yet we're so excited for solo
Kacey Musgraves and I have to listen to
like all the screaming fans of Harry
Styles yeah we were also feeling happy
and sad at the same time right now what
is your favorite song to perform I think
maybe slow burn I think it's it feels
real good like it feels like I can find
my supplies in that's what we need right
now because we're we're out of control
and we're out of control what can we
offer you
are you a tequila gal I figured as much
kindred spirits and you know what I
haven't taken a shot with anyone but I'm
going here oh wait okay wow this is so
exciting
you look so beautiful by the way rich
here you go
I saw you walk by and I was like oh
great I'm never gonna talk to Kasey
Musgraves and now here I am don't join
us out yourself drinking with Kacey
Musgraves
cheers what are you testing to tonight I
I don't know just like still being alive
I guess okay yeah and shutting the album
of the year
album of the year now I remember my tan
ticket yours just so everything I love
you more than life itself
thank you I just got another my birthday
well it's not you're rich what is it
Alessandra rich she's rare like a little
they're very famous I'm not gonna lie oh
they are though I'm like about to go
Google's out right now well you're like
your aesthetic is like I feel like
you're so in control of what you wear
and what your set looks like and what
everyone around you wears and you always
have been like from the little blue
outfits and like the cactus vibe to now
just like sparkly AF with long rosy
azulene vials shut up now we see you
everything she makes and it's so fun to
wear I just like to have fun with my
clothes Erica and you're not married I
don't meet you
wedding was like Pinterest to the
highest level well I'm just like so
afraid that's the last time I'm gonna
get to talk to you that I need to ask
you everything I've ever thought okay
John I don't want anyone to know you
want to take the opportunity to talk
about dime-store cowgirl and have that
Shawn takes your life I know you'd be
remiss if you did not thank you for this
is why she's a good sister where since
you reminded me
even better times for cowgirl is it's
not even a sad song but it makes me cry
every time you say that because my dad
and I don't know why and the song is
about an insult it's supposed to be like
it's supposed to be like super like
happy and I'm just like I am a
dime-store cowgirl and I just I am and I
think that's a compliment now it's like
you've changed it into a compliment well
thanks also I just realized I'm not even
holding this I'm so lazy no I'm just
I wanted to everything I can for you to
stay here as long as possible
do you have any pizza oh no but I'll get
you time I'll get you some okay I know
you have to go because you're like so
important but thank you for coming to
our little show
you